If you're having some election day jitters,
like I know I am, just remember that this is not gonna be done today.
They're gonna recount.
There's no way that this is gonna be a one and done
counting of the ballots, okay?
So sit back, don't get too anxious about the results tonight,
because we are going through a recount no matter what, okay?
I think we all know that. So just sit back,
breathe. If you've voted,
you've done your part.
If you need to take a little break from social media,
because you don't need to see the pundits and the people
and the talking heads going back and forth about what.
Just wait, just breathe.
And if you need bottle wine